EIJI KITAMURA: Web
Components enable
you to build great
websites through the use
of reusable components.
But what does it take to
build a web component?
My name is Eiji,
and today I'm going
to give you an overview
of Custom Elements.
Custom Elements
are a key feature
in Web Components that lets
you create your own HTML tags.
Given the original purpose of
HTML tags as a script language
for documents, it has
a limited vocabulary
for elements, which
means we end up
relying on divs and existing
markup to structure pages.
Custom Elements
will change that.
Some frameworks,
such as AngularJS,
provides a way to
define your own tags.
But, they are specific to the
framework, and not reusable.
With Custom Elements, you
can define and register
new Dom elements, as well
as inherit and extend
existing DOM elements.
These differences make Custom
Elements easier to handle,
not only for element
authors, but also
for developers who use them.
At the time of this
recording, Custom Elements
have landed in Chrome and Opera.
Firefox supports it
innately behind a flag.
But support for Web
Components is changing weekly,
so be sure to check
chromestatus.com
for an up to date
browser support table.
To detect the availability
of the custom element,
check if document register
element is available.
For supported browsers,
you can use platform.js,
a collection of web
components polyfill
made available as a part
of the Polymer library.
This will automatically detect
the availability of the Custom
Elements and polyfill
it, if necessary.
Registering a Custom
Element is simple.
Just call document
register element,
with a new tag name
as an argument.
This will register a new tag
name, in this case x component,
which you can then start
using in your document.
The tag name must be
separated with a dash.
Anything other than
that will return errors.
You can use those
custom elements,
not only declaratively
as an HTML tag,
but also imperatively,
using JavaScript.
One way is to use the
constructor written
by document register element.
You can instantiate
the constructor
to obtain a DOM object.
Because Custom Elements are just
like any other HTML element,
you may also use
document create element
to create a new instance.
Once you learn how to define
and register a custom tag,
you should also want to
add some features to it.
You can do so by inheriting an
existing element's prototype.
First, create a new object
from HTML element prototype
by using object create.
This new object will be the
prototype for your element.
Then add your own properties
and message to it.
When registering
the Custom Element,
[INAUDIBLE] object has a second
argument, which has a prototype
object with a value
of key prototype.
Now, you can use the x component
Custom Element in your HTML.
If you inspect the x component
element on Dev Tools,
it will look
something like this.
X component element
is an instance
of x component
prototype, which has
a property and the method
you have just defined,
alert and name.
And this element is
inherited from HTML element,
so it has all the features
HTML element provides.
You can also extend
an existing element,
which is called type
extension custom element.
To extend an element, give the
second argument in register
element, an object with
extends and prototype as keys.
For extends, give it a tag name
string you want to extend from.
For example, input.
For prototype, give it the
best element's prototype.
If you are extending
from input element,
use HTML input element.
For using type extension
custom element,
add the custom element's
name as a value of
is attribute to the
extended element.
To imperatively recreate a
DOM object of the element,
and the tag name as the second
argument to create element.
You may wonder what our use
cases for type extension custom
element?
Actually, there's already
a really good example
in the world.
If you go to
GitHub, you can find
lots of sections that
indicates relative time.
If you take a look into one
of them using Dev Tools,
you will notice it
is actually a time
tag with an extension
of relative time.
Notice that the
datetime attribute
indicates an absolute time.
This is achieved by using
type extension custom element.
The relative time type
extension automatically
calculates relative
time, and appends it
to the time element
as a text content.
To learn more about the
time element, please
visit its GitHub repository.
I mentioned that the relative
time type extension appends
a string to the element
as a text content.
But when does that happen?
Custom elements support
life cycle callbacks
that enable you to manipulate
DOM on certain timings.
There are four types
life cycle callbacks.
Created callback, this is called
after the element is created.
Attached callback,
this is called
when the element is
attached to the document.
Detached callback,
this is called
when the element is
detached from the document.
Attribute changed
callback, this is
called when one of the
element's attributes is changed.
Relative time type
extension hooks
in to created
callback and attribute
changed callback, and
manipulates the element's text
content.
In order to use those
lifecycle callbacks,
you can simply add them
to the prototype object
when registering
a custom element.
Once inside of
created callback, you
can leverage the power of
template and Shadow DOM
to add additional
content to our element.
Let me show you an example.
So this is a template, we are
adding Custom Elements content
followed by an actual HTML that
displays the custom element.
Since this is exactly the same
code we used in the Shadow DOM
video, I'm not
going to explain how
to use template and Shadow DOM.
If you haven't watched
them, please do so.
For JavaScript, we can
use a similar skeleton
as we used in the
earlier example.
In order to create
shadow root, first,
add created callback as a
property of custom elements
prototype.
Then, call create shadow
root on this object.
To stamp out template, pick
the template DOM element,
using querySelector Then, clone
it using document import node,
and append it to
the shadow root.
And finally, register
the custom element.
The result will look
something like this.
So this is the custom element.
To learn more about
custom elements,
be sure to read the HTML5
Rocks article, written
by Eric Bidelman.
Thank you for watching.
See you in the next episode.